andré confié en composant le 18 ce matin
ça fonctionne dans ce centre du val
d'oise hier cette émission quasi
impossible de manière aléatoire on
recevait ou ne recevait plus les appels
d'urgence de 16h45 à minuit même
situation dans tous les départements
français
les numéros de remplacement sont
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux tandis
qu'au ministère de l'intérieur une salle
de crise est activée
gérald darmanin évoque des
dysfonctionnements graves inacceptables
et des conséquences tragiques pour au
moins trois personnes en déplacement
dans le lot
emmanuel macron s'est dit très préoccupé
toutefois il est selon lui trop tôt pour
faire un bilan sera pas une émission
jusqu'à jeudi prochain
est ce que s'est passé avec les normes
non il ya eu des drames à eric bouillard
qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier je crois
que je crois qu'on l'a vu par image
c'est à dire que y'a manière aléatoire
sur l'ensemble du territoire français le
15 17 le 18 ou le 112
vous avez pas eu d'appel hier soir
regardons vous ai dit un problème à un
moment donné effectivement il ya de
toute façon dans ce genre de situations
bien entendu que on est alerté bien en
allemand c'est vrai qu'aussi au regard
de la population qui essayait de
transmettre un moment donné des
situations alarmantes apparaît nettement
vous êtes dit il ya un souci là ça
commence de manière très simple de dire
que en fait on a déjà des données qui
proviennent effectivement déjà des
infrastructures de télécommunication et
puis au delà de ça c'est effectivement
les difficultés quand on entend à pro
téléphone et d'ailleurs on peut saluer
le travail de l'ensemble des opérateurs
que ce soit 5000 que ce soit les
pompiers que ce soit aussi la police et
la gendarmerie qui ont su garder le sang
froid et le calme de pouvoir expliquer
ces relents moisis face à des
difficultés pouvait y avoir des
énervements ce que les gens ne pouvaient
pas comprendre un moment donné donc il a
fallu à mon asso à ce juste à ce juste
titre même pouvoir à un moment donné
comprendre ce qui se passe en amont voir
résoudre apporter les solutions idoines
mais quand on voit déjà le bilan qui est
dès lors il ya un blu ray qui est très
loin
conseillez vous rendez coupe en fait on
se rend compte de ça quand quand on a
donc sur une pâle comme ça c'est la
première fois que ça arrive c'est la
première fois de cette grande ampleur
effectivement que ça arrive
effectivement c'est parfois
effectivement il peut y avoir des
surcharges savez il ya des situations de
crise qui sont éco même assez assez
prononcée et on les a connus que ce soit
dans les crises naturelles ou autres
ou un moment donné la capacité à pouvoir
absorber la sueur des appels se fait
mais sur les structures des sapeurs
pompiers
comme pour le reste son on va dire doté
de salles de débordements ce qu'on
appelle en situation d'urgence il en
salles de traitement de l'alerté pour
pouvoir moment de les basculer des
appels sur d'autres postes de secours
mais néanmoins aujourd'hui le conseil
était fait et c'était qu'il a fallu
remplacer l'ensemble des numéros
d'urgence de chaque département sur par
des numéros à 10 chiffres avec dans
chaque département au nombre à chaque
fois du samu et des sapeurs pompiers et
de la police
ce qui à démultiplier le nombre de
numéros à 10 chiffres alors qu'on
arriverait à une solution d'eau numéro
unique on arrivait tous incessamment par
remplacement tout simplement à numéros à
10 chiffres
alors justement d'en parler parce que
peut-être qu'il va y avoir des dvd à
mouvaux aménagements qui vont être
faites peut-être qu'on n'aura plus qu'un
numéro je sais pas ce qui va se passer
mais pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi hier
soir à partir de 18h de graves problèmes
ont touché les numéros d'urgence dans
tout le pays il était donc impossible de
joindre le samu et les policiers les
pompiers dans la plupart des
départements français pour pallier à ce
problème donc ils ont mis en place
d'autres numéros pour chaque de marque
département mais tout le monde forcément
n'était pas au courant de ces numéros
donc les gens étaient chez eux ils
appelaient 18 il est le dix est
impossible d'avoir quelqu'un à midi la
situation était apparemment revenu à la
normale dans plusieurs départements
alors j'ai été mis en cause orange
notamment
qu'est-ce que vous pourrez répondre aux
gens aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé d'où vient cette panne je pense
qu'il faut revenir à l'histoire du
téléphone l'histoire du téléphone c'est
une histoire qui a permis au fur et à
mesure du développement du téléphone de
sauver des vies bah oui de sauver des
vies parce que quand on a eu le
téléphone installé chez soi alors
beaucoup de nos concitoyennes s'en
souviennent plus mais on pouvait appeler
le 15 le 17 le 18 dans les années 80 et
ça a permis de sauver beaucoup de vies
quand la téléphonie mobile est arrivée
elle a aussi commencé à permettre à
sauver de sauver de nouvelle vie les
accidents de la route par exemple mais
les accidents les accents je vais y
venir et les accidents de la route
vu leur mortalité baissé parce que les
services d'intervention ne pouvait
arriver plus rapidement mais ce système
de développement de l'économie numérique
de la téléphonie ne cesse de se
complexifier c'est à dire qu'au fil du
temps on rajoute des technologies
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire que d'abord
on a eu la téléphonie fixe a puis
ensuite on à la téléphonie sur internet
qui passe par votre box on à la
téléphonie mobile
on a une médication des opérateurs et on
a une infrastructure on a une dynamique
générale qui ne cesse de se complexifier
et qui fait qu ensuite une fois que tous
ses appels arrivent ils doivent être
ensuite redistribués vers le centre
d'urgence le plus le plus proche
vous appelez à strasbourg vous êtes
priés vous appeler le 15 a strasbourg
évidemment il ne faut pas que vous
tombiez à lyon parce que ça ne servira
pas à grand-chose à dire d'où cette page
concrètement elle vient du fait que
notre nono système se complexifie au fil
du temps et que avec cette
complexification qui s'introduit
progressivement à tous les niveaux du
système les bas il ya des pannes
aléatoire et hier on a été confronté à
une palette moment on a entendu parler
de la thèse d'une cyberattaque l écarter
couple de blancs cette thèse ah oui à
date à date ya aucune aucune trace d'une
cyberattaque et ceci et ouais totalement
exclue en revanche il est vrai sont là
qu'on ait une panne logiciel qui
nécessite une surveillance et de d'euros
réfléchir peut-être à comment se
prémunir d'un système qui est à la base
très fragile et qui connaît des pannes
quasiment
jamais sauf évidemment hier mais il faut
savoir que ces numéros d'urgence sont
extrêmement malmené par exemple lors des
intempéries ou là c'est tout notre
réseau qui tombe et on peut plus appeler
non plus alors gilles verdié mais
excusez moi monsieur mais orange
opérateur à une obligation de résultats
en la matière vous pouvez pas nous dire
oui on est saturé
il ya eu une panne vous n'avez pas le
choix vous êtes payé pour réussir
d'ailleurs au plus haut niveau du chef
de l'état tout le monde s'en émeut c'est
incroyable ce qui s'est passé j'avais
l'impression d'être dans un pays du
tiers-monde monsieur c'est à dire qu'on
est incapable d'assurer des personnes
âgées chez elles malades qui n'ont pas
plu du tout à plessé vient nous
expliquer sébastien mais ce qui s'est
passé je pense que vous posez une bonne
question est ce que ça de vrai un
service marchand ou un service de la
nation
nous avons fait le choix dans notre pays
de faire en sorte que les télécoms soit
comme une boîte de corn flakes sur les
étagères de supermarché évidemment quand
il s'agit hélas
la situation le montre quand il s'agit
des services vitaux de la nation
peut-on considérer que c'est soumis à
des contraintes marchandes à des appels
d'offres qui soit au prix et qu'ils
soient éventuellement aux prix des vies
de nos concitoyens je crois pas je crois
qu'il faut réfléchir à la concurrence
dans le secteur des télécoms pour que
les services essentiels de la nation
puisse être assurée sans risque 1 pour
nos concitoyens
là c'est les services d'urgence il ya
des questions de cybersécurité il ya des
questions de souveraineté nationale
oui télécom sont est un service
essentiel pour la nation alors c'est
vrai qu'à tout le monde a réagi
aujourd'hui olivier viron évoqué une
suspicion d'au moins trois ou quatre
décès qui pourrait être lié même là
c'est pas aujourd'hui il ya gérald
darmanin aussi mise de l'intérieur qui a
expliqué qu'il s'agissait de quelque
chose d'inacceptable votre pdg stéphane
richard a été convoqué d'ailleurs par le
ministère l'intérieur dans les coûts
tant j'étais tf1 comprenez qu'il
s'agissait d'un événement assez
gravissime regarder trouve que pour une
raison que nous ne connaissons pas au
moment où nous parlons
croyez moi j'imagine que d'autres à
chelsea son temps en investigation
poussée pour essayer de comprendre
exactement la cause racines de ce
dysfonctionnement c'est plus
probablement une défaillance logiciel
dans ses équipements critiques de réseau
elles ont touché l'intégralité des six
sites en même temps ça ça n'est jamais
arrivé
c'est un incident effectivement grave
c'est clair
rarissime rarissime qui a pu arriver
dans le monde des télécoms de temps en
temps mais c'est très rare
heureusement se soient rarissimes mais
c'est vrai qu orange a décidé éminent de
faire de la communication de que le
communiqué l'histoire de notre
entreprise c'est celle du téléphone donc
toutes ces vies que nous avons sauvé au
cours des dernières décennies et que
nous continuons à sauver chaque jour et
que nous continuerons à sauver parce que
nous mettons un système qui permet à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens d'appeler
dans les meilleures conditions
on l'oubli mais par exemple si vous
n'avez pas la couverture sur le réseau
bouygues
quand vous êtes à la campagne et que
vous avez la couverture d'un autre
opérateur orange par exemple
imaginez que vous faites le 112 et
l'appel est acheminé ou inversement si
vous n'avez pas la couverture orange et
vous avez la couverture bouygues
oui acheminera la communication donc on
voit bien que ces éléments sont
essentiels et on le met le corps social
et personnel d'orange sont très affectés
par le fait que ce dysfonctionnement
c'est une c considéré en interne comme
une faute vis-à-vis de la nation parce
que effectivement il ya des vies en jeu
parce que on verra si les enquêtes
démontrent que la l'incapacité d'appeler
a été la cause des décès mais en tous
les cas c'est c'est effectivement une
sidération et est très mal vécue par par
l'ensemble du personnel non mais
j'entends tout à fait ce que vous dites
le système votre système est fragile
mais puisque vous savez que le système
est fragile et là en l'occurrence les
répercussions sont terribles
effectivement on parle d'au moins 3 cas
de personnes décédées qui pourrait
l'être parce que ils n'ont pas été
secouru à temps puisque vous savez que
ce système est fragile pourquoi vous
n'avez pas évoqué comme comme disait
monsieur à ce moment là la mise en place
éventuelle d'un numéro qui serait un
numéro qui récupère le 15e 17e 18 qui
serait un numéro de secours qui se met
en branle au moment où éventuellement il
ya une défaillance pourquoi ça n'existe
pas déjà eric eric voulait réagir at il
justement à le préciser c'est que nous
on essaie les sapeurs-pompiers de vrai
et je retiens certains termes même si on
n'est pas dans une même politique comme
l'avait évoqué marchande alors que nous
on a une politique de service public et
de rendu à la population au plus près de
la population
constamment et je retiens deux points
essentiels qui ont été évoqués qui sont
extrêmement importants c'est l'histoire
déjà qui permet aujourd'hui que le 15 et
le 17 et le 18 date des années 80 et la
société effectivement évolué et je
rejoue jours vont tout à fait dans la
mesure où derrière on le voit derrière
le téléphone mobile aujourd'hui personne
ne sait comment fonctionne le 112 alors
que même si vous n'avez pas activer
votre carte sim
ça fonctionne quand même même si vous
pas de réseau il a expliqué derrière ça
met en service et l'ensemble des
faisceaux lorsqu'on demande nous
aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers et
comme on l'a évoqué la d1 fort lors
d'une proposition de loi matraque qui
passe à l'assemblée nationale c'est
d'instaurer ce fameux numéro unique
d'urgence qui est le 112 de manière à ce
que demain face à toute situation on
puisse automatiquement rentrer dans un
tout simplement devant un portail ou
derrière ben on va être dirigée
correctement et avoir un seul numéro
parce que c'est vrai on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu effectivement
une grosse faille technique on peut le
pire est derrière nous avons mis en
oeuvre dans l'ensemble des départements
ce qu'on appelle tout simplement d'une
attitude dégradé face à cette situation
les sapeurs pompiers savent se réadapter
ce qu'on a vu aussi surtout c'est que
enfin pour certains départements ça a
très bien marché pour des plateformes
uniques comme le 74 savoie ou dans la
même pièce il y avait le samu et les
pompiers la police qui automatiquement
se sont vus se sont concertés pour
essayer d'optimiser l'envoi de secours
malgré ce cette attitude dégradé de la
situation mais néanmoins d'autres
départements ils n'étaient pas connectés
entre eux ils étaient répartis à
quelques kilomètres entre ce qui était
très difficile par rapport à ça et je
tiens encore à saluer l'ensemble des
opérateurs quels qu'ils soient
samu pompiers et gendarmerie et police
qui ont permis à un moment donné
d'essayer d'entrecouper les informations
et essayer de comprendre mais quand vous
êtes à des milliers de camphin pour
certains à des centaines de kilomètres
entre eux c'est extrêmement compliqué
surtout que vous avez un nombre de
postes téléphoniques à l'intérieur d'une
salle qui est quand même limité ray et
quand vous faites au niveau des sapeurs
pompiers puis 18 millions d'appels par
jour par en parlant excusez-moi vin par
jour comme certains le disaient mais que
d'autres que les sapeurs pompiers
effectuent une intervention toutes les
6,5 secondes et que on va dire
l'essentiel l'essentiel de liens avec la
population c'est ce rapport téléphonique
bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui il faut le
repenser parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
utilisez votre téléphone que ce soit des
applications de messagerie instantanée
qui utilisent je pas le site et ça
commence par un w ça finit par ap mais
la fonction téléphone pour appeler
directement son collègue via cette
application on est aujourd'hui toutes
ses habitudes là est ce que je veux dire
c'est que à partir de là il ou est ce la
fin pareil là c'est autre chose mais ce
qu'on veut dire par rapport à cela c'est
que les habitudes ont changé
la population a changé et ce qu'on a
remarqué c'est l'essentiel c'est le
retour à repenser l'humain dans ce genre
de situation c'est le retour à l'humain
et l'éducation face au risque face à la
résilience qui contacte avec peut-être
ses grands-parents pour lui signaler
parce que moi mes parents ne sont pas
sur les réseaux sociaux mais assurent
contre il fallait leur indiquant numéros
à 10 chiffres ou les rassure en disant
si tu as besoin de quelque chose vient
le vent je suis à côté
le rapport avec le social le rapport
avec le voisinage tout ça hier on l'a vu
à un moment donné on se retourne et on
s'est dit mais c'est pas possible
humainement c'est une enseigne et ça
j'en envoie une liste de messages de
numéro de téléphone mais simplifié les
choses ont parlé tout à l'heure de
complexe nous on est là pour simplifier
de mettre tout le monde derrière
même table derrière décion même salle de
manière à ce qu'on puisse communiquer
correctement sur l'attitude samassi un
projet est ce que vous allez prendre des
mesures pour ça n'arrive plus ce que
vous êtes déjà en train de travailler
avec vos équipes parce que c'est ce qu'a
dit waldo d'euros due d'une part d'une
part ya forcément une enquête il ya une
analyse y aura des résultats il y aura
une compréhension de ce qui s'est passé
mais au delà du travail qui est fait en
aval qui hélas l'éventuelle
simplification de travers d'un numéro
unique qui nous introduit quand même de
la complexité parce que nos algorithmes
d'acheminement ne sont pas les mêmes
pour acheminer le 15 pour acheminer le
18 que pour acheminer le 17 puisqu'on
achemine pas au même endroit mais
au-delà de ça il faut aussi une
concertation entre l'ensemble des
acteurs de la chaîne parce que nous nous
répondons à une demande du ministère de
l'économie sur ce sujet qui s'appelle le
service universel dans lesquelles les
numéros d'urgence ont inclus et si
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont les
opérateurs se mettent autour de la table
pour définir des standards des normes
des règles plus simple on aura un
système qui soit plus robuste parce que
plus un système est simple plus il est
robuste alors il attend déroulée
aujourd'hui à date à date aujourd'hui
les équipes sont mobilisées sont en
situation de surveillance on ne constate
pas d'appel qui n'aboutissent pas donc
c'est vrai que de façon anormale pour
autant les équipes sont sur le pont
toute la nuit
parce que
le temps que l'analyse de la cause et sa
répétabilité trouver la cause encore
écouter pour l'instant on a des pistes
on a on a des présomptions mais mais on
va pas faire des tests en grandeur
nature pour voir si c'était si la panne
et reproductive donc vous imaginez bien
que en est en train de mettre en place
des outils de mesure de tester danalyse
parallèle pour pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé mais en
tous les cas plusieurs centaines de
collaborateurs du groupe sont à sur le
pont cette nuit demain est sans doute ce
week end pour faire que ça ne se
reproduise pas worth qui est ce qu'on
pensait des spectateurs oui 86 pour son
don à 4 conscience de desbiens bien sûr
du résultat du sondage